combinando arte y atletismo el
breakdance ha emocionado a los
espectadores en las esquinas de las
calles de todo el mundo desde la década
de 1970
ahora tiene luz verde para actuar en el
escenario más grande del deporte una
decisión que muchos esperan ayude a
darle más reconocimiento
me hizo muy feliz especialmente por las
personas que allanaron el camino para mi
generación creo que no hay una semana en
la que no haya pensado en los juegos
olímpicos durante el año pasado así que
ha sido realmente emocionante
el breakdance también conocido como
break para su debut en los juegos de
parís 2024 los bailes tendrán lugar en
una ubicación privilegiada en el corazón
de la capital francesa los competidores
son juzgados tanto por sus habilidades
técnicas como por su creatividad y
estilo
si bien la mayoría de la comunidad break
ha aceptado su inclusión algunos han
expresado su preocupación porque su
cultura y autenticidad se pierden en una
plataforma más grande para richard colom
uno de los pioneros del break su
incorporación trata de aumentar las
cifras de audiencia para los juegos
olímpicos y ya nos hemos legitimado así
que no buscamos legitimidad en los
productos limpios el caso es que sólo
puede esperar que aportemos más interés
a los juegos olímpicos creo que en
realidad es al revés que va a hacer el
break dance para los juegos olímpicos
se estima que un millón de personas
practican breakdance en todo el mundo el
surf el skate y la escalada deportiva
también se han agregado al programa de
los juegos olímpicos en un intento por
atraer a los espectadores más jóvenes